house of the dragon the game of thrones
prequel series that
airs in 2022 on hbo has been filming for
months now
and you can expect to see the
live-action trailer with most of the
characters very soon
in fact a very limited amount of people
that mostly includes the press have
already seen it
and they all liked it all of you will
see it soon as well i promise
but before that let me introduce to you
the main characters of the show
as most of you already know house of the
dragon is based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book fire and blood
that begins its tale with the legendary
egg on the conqueror
creator of the iron throne and goes all
the way up to the targaryen civil war
that nearly destroyed house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the fire and
blood part 2 will continue from where
part 1 ended
with rynero targaryen's son aegon iii's
reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions
worthy thorne
and go all the way to the met king and
robert sabellian that tended targaryen
dynasty
this particular show house of the dragon
will cover the dance of the dragons
if you're more interested in other time
periods do not worry
because hb is working on total of 6 game
of thrones prequel shows
anyways back to our main characters of
the house of the dragon
since the key event of the show is the
dance of the dragons the targaryen civil
war
which is also the key event in the
history of house targaryen
as you might have guessed it targaryens
are mostly the main characters
season 1 of house of the dragon will see
a build up towards the dance of the
dragons
the show will not jump straight into a
targaryen civil war
it will start with a prelude with king
viserys the first sitting on the iron
throne and with a huge rivalry between
his children
on one side we have king viserys's
daughter and chosen heir
rhaenyra supported by her father's
cousin
rhaenys targaryen slash valerian her
uncle daemon targaryen
and cordless valerian the sea snake
among many more
on the other hand we have rhaenyra's
younger half sibling
aegon targaryen supported by his mother
queen ellis and hightower
his grandfather otto hightower who is
the hand of the king
answer kristen cole who is the lord
commander of the kingsguard
all the names i just mentioned will be
the main characters in season 1 of house
of the dragon
in the first few episodes the animosity
at the court between rhaenyra supporters
and aegon supporters will also be
established
king viserys the first targaryen is the
one who sits on the iron throne at the
beginning of the series
he is the fifth targaryen king to sit on
the iron throne
viserys is a dragon rider who rode the
legendary valyrian the black dread
until the dragon died of old age viserys
has a brother
daemon targaryen the most controversial
man of his lifetime
who at this point of the series is the
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea
wielding valyrian steel blade dark
sister daemon is considered by many to
be the most dangerous man in westeros
he is the best fighter general and
commander
and he will prove everyone right in the
upcoming war
but back to viserys viserys had three
children by his first wife
marin but only one princess rhaenyra
survived to adulthood
lacking a son to succeed him with
viserys began to train rhaenyra to be
his heir
named her his heir and rhaenyra soon
acquired support of hundreds of lords
and landed knights
the king remarried in 106 ac this time
to alice and hightower
and had four more children aegon helena
amend and daeron in 111ac a great
tourney was held at king's landing
on the fifth anniversary of azaris
marriage to ellison
during the opening feast queen ellis
sent wore a green gown
while princess rhaenyra dressed in red
and black of house targaryen
note was taken and soon all of
rhaenyra's supporters started wearing
black clothing
while all of ellison's followers started
wearing green
over the time the popular names applied
to both factions were inspired by the
colors they wore
rhaenyra's supporters were called the
blacks and diego the second supporters
were called the greens
viserys the first strengthened
rhaenyra's place in the succession by
marrying her in 114 ac
to the son of the sea snake sterling or
valerian
who himself had targaryen blood through
his mother princess rhaenys
rhaenyra gave birth to three sons
jacarius losers and joffrey valerian
during her marriage
although there were rumors that the
father of those princes was not
laner butts are harming strong
one way or the other house valerian
plays huge roles since the very
beginning of the show
and they'll play a huge role up until
the end
the most famous and strongest valerian
to ever live is also one of the main
characters in the upcoming
house of the dragon shout coreless
valerian known as the sea snake
he is a fable the lord of the tides
during targaryen's civil war
master of driftmark and the head of
house valerian that's been loyal ally to
the targaryens since aegon the conqueror
during the conquest it was valerian
ships that carried aegon soldiers
across blackwater bay and later formed
the greater part of the royal fleet
going even further back into history
house valerian much like house targaryen
is from valyria
he's the husband of another main
character princess rhaenys targaryen
the queen who never once during the
dance of the dragons
he even becomes the hand to queen
rhaenyra targaryen
who is his niece and daughter-in-law
after laner was executed in spicetown
in 128c rhaenyra married the other main
character her uncle
infamous rogue prince prince daemon
targaryen
younger brother to be there is the first
her sons by him are reagan the younger
called so to distinguish him from his
uncle alice and sagon
who on occasion is called aegon the
elder and viserys
the relationship between rhaenyra and
alison declined early in alison's
marriage to viserys
since both ladies had been trying to be
the realm's first lady
and there could only be one alison's
father seroto hightower
had also disliked rhaenyra's second
husband prince daemon
since the beginning of his service's
reign so up until this point of season
one
they will learn much and more about
these characters their intentions and
their loyalties
the war begins towards the end of season
one when our first main character king
viserys dies and his children the other
two main characters rhaenyra and aegon
each proclaimed themselves the rightful
heir to the throne
and the other six main characters rally
between one or the other
for reiner it's her husband daemon
targaryen
her own blood rhaenys and her husband
coral is the sea snake valerian
again there's many more who support
rhaenyra
namely how serene and how stark
represented by the legendary craig and
stark
but at this point of the show they are
not the main characters yet
for aegon it's his mother alison
grandfather otto and sir kristen cole
although there are many more supporting
him as well
namely house lannister who has their own
man at king's landing court
thailand lannister but they are not the
main characters
this is when the war begins but not war
of fire and blood
but war of ravens for now let me also
tell you that
at this point of the story 20 dragons
are alive
but majority will not be by the time
this story is over
so as i said targaryen civil war begins
towards the end of season 1
when king viserys dies his designated
heir
for many years had been his only
surviving child by his
first wife his daughter rhaenyra
since viserys later remarried however
and had several younger children by his
second wife
alison hightower the eldest of which is
aegon
half of the lords of the seven kingdoms
side with king's chosen heir
and king zelda's child rhaenyra while
the other half of westeros
sides with king zelda's male son aegon
the seven kingdoms had never had a
ruling queen before
and many were troubled by the thought of
rhaenyra succeeding to determine
by the inheritance laws of the andals a
younger brother succeeds ahead of an
elder daughter
but the targaryens had never formalized
the royal
inheritance laws for their new realm
after the war of conquest 130 years
before
with there is the first to have ever had
extracted oaths of filthy from the major
lords of the realm
that's why nera would succeed him
anyways as soon as king viserys dies
queen ellis sent hightower conceals
viserys's death from the public
and instead has sir kristen cole the
lord commander of the kingsguard
some and a small council to alison's
apartments in maegor's holdfest
kristen who once served rhaenyra
convinced viserys's son prince aegon the
elder
to claim the rule of the seven kingdoms
as his father lay dead
for this he became known as kristen the
king maker
viserys had decorated his heir to be
rhaenyra targaryen
princess of dragonstone the daughter
from his first wife
emma rin the green said the red keeps
support egg on the elder
the eldest son of his second wife alison
however
and kristen takes into custody any
blacks remaining at court
alice sent forbid septons and silent
sisters from treating viserys's body
a week after viserys's death his passing
is finally
publicly revealed with the greens
accounting the ascension of fagon ii
targaryen
the silent sisters then prepared the
late king's body for traditional burning
of a targaryen
at dragonstone rhaenyra finds out that
her father died
and aegon staged a coup and was crowned
king in king's landing
she refuses to recognize the claim of
aegon her younger half-brother and the
blacks instead support her as queen
rhaenyra is princess of dragonstone has
her power base on dragonstone island
where she responds by being crowned
queen by daemon
and declaring a a traitor the rival
claims to viserys's inheritance leads to
the dance of the dragons
the civil war between the blacks and the
greens the very war in which most of the
characters will die along with their
dragons
whose claim do you support aegon's or
rhaenyras
who's your favorite character and which
dragon are you looking forward to see
the most
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace